[Music]
thank you very small I saw the last
night it was really funny y'all are very
cute in it have you ever had a night go
completely off the rails though but in
the best way so I'm gonna start with you
Camille on that one what was the night
that you were like okay this just went
completely nuts but it was actually
really fun well I you know for New
Year's a lot of people I know don't like
going out I Love New Year's Eve I want
to go out I want to do all the things
Emily definitely like let's just have
some friends and just and I'm like no
we're doing it these are the four
parties were going to and one time in
New York we were like I didn't do it
right and we got stuck you know in
between like we're stuck in a cab for
midnight and and it turned out to be
this they actually turned out to be
really really fun because it sort of
took that pressure off that moment you
know because that puts so much pressure
on New Year's Eve you can ask you can
ask Emily about it I get way too excited
about New Year's oh really
that is not my holiday I think yeah like
the worst holiday to go I know
everything about it that says a lot I
love that you love everything about it
so ISA I'm gonna ask you this one
because it's a big pop point of movie so
do you have the person that you would do
the Amazing Race with and or do you have
someone that you like maybe our friends
would be like but that person I know if
I did the Amazing Race we would win I
think I would probably do the Amazing
Race with any of my best friends I think
they would for sure get frustrated with
me as they realize my weakness but
they're all so smart and so capable and
may they take charge in a way that I
love and I feel like iíve I'd you know
I'm I have hiked woman energy and I like
to communicate pretty well so I bring
that to the table but yeah beyond that I
don't want to take a chance with anybody
else because I don't want to let anybody
else down you know second one Camille do
you have your amazing grace partner you
don't feel like you have to say your
what I for me it could be like any
I think it would be my wife oh yeah
we've really been through some stuff
together so even if there would be
conflict I feel like we would be able to
resolve it and she's just very organized
and great it like making lists so I
think and she's a great under pressure
you know so I think I think Emily would
be a good partner for amazing west-east
I'll ask you this in the time that we've
been sort of like quarantined I feel
like this is the perfect movie for
couples to watch with each other and
maybe appreciate their relationships
because you learn a lot what have you
learned maybe about your friends
yourself during this time so like kind
of maybe stand still a little bit I've
learned that I thought it was you know I
tend to get really frustrated easily or
so I thought but I'm like okay maybe I
am a patient person and that's that's a
valuable trait to have I have to ask
this because it's rotten tomatoes and
they're very curious is there anything
you can tell us about the Eternals if
there is anything because everybody
wants to know
I'm sure there's not but I'm oh yeah
well here's the big plot point that
nobody knows so they took just oh I
shouldn't have said that
yeah guy that is the best thing that has
ever happened to us
I appreciate that all right that's it
guys thank you guys so much I really
appreciate it
their system and mates - Oh [ __ ]
we have imposters oh no imposter that
sucks
everyone unmask you're saying oh sure
nobody else took that mask
I'm gonna give you lovebirds a choice
what's behind this door or banking grace
- the fight
I don't wanna grease on my bias